welcome everyone and so we'll start up
by going over one of my games I played
right before the Olympiad last year in a
tournament in la la Metro international
tournament in this scheme my opponent is
the international master David pros and
I'm playing with the white pieces here
so ok d4 Knight f6 c4 g6 this K this
game sound what a surprise for me
because I remember him playing some
other openings so I didn't expect him to
play the groom felt in this game
so I played here played d5 so we have
the green field defense here and many
different ways you can play here and for
example there was a game today where
Kuryakin plate f3 in this position
against giri and this is you know this
move is actually getting more and more
popular in particular Anand won a very
quick game against guilt on teto
championship match last year so it's a
very interesting move to analyse if
you're looking for a the set up against
the groom phone and also this if you
place Bishop g7 you can play e4 and you
play the same ish Samish setup so this
is interesting I play this sometimes
against the Kings Indian also but in
this game after 93 he played d5 and I
played Bishop g5 this is my main move
against the grünfeld but I've played
many different systems in this position
I've played CTX d5 the mainlines Knight
takes d5 d4 Knight X III pawn takes c3
Bishop g7 Knight f3 C 5 and after rook
e1 is just a lots of theory that you
need to know here for white it's a very
interesting positions but again you have
to spend a lot of time analyzing and
going over the latest games
and see what is the theory at this point
so but I play Bishop g5 because you're
on you know you don't have to you have
to know the theory a little bit but not
too much you basically can play this
position by by the field so it plays
Knight e4 activating the knight and
attacking bishop so you play Bishop h4
here actually 90 X e4 is kind of
considered bad but few years ago more as
a witch tried this move against Carlsen
so it's it's not that bad at all
actually and I'm thinking maybe if I can
analyze a little bit more dispositions
maybe to try it one day so the way it
works here after D takes it's very
important for you to play Queen d2 here
first because if you play III after c5
there is this unpleasant check on a5 and
you shouldn't allow black to exchange on
d4 because if you allow them to exchange
in after Bishop g7 96 is going to have
very strong pressure on d4 so that's why
you play Queen d2 first in this position
and this is how motors average play
calls on play Bishop g7 III c 5b v now
now you can play this one because your
queen is only to controlling the a5
square he cannot check and also now
you're protecting the pawn on b2 so this
is a very interesting game I mean there
is further now analysis needs to be done
on this game but looks like it's a
playable position white probably doesn't
have much advantage but you can
definitely play like this and this way
you also you know a lot of the main
lines you will have to deal with
basically Knight comes to c3 and so in
some point black played f5 and nine goes
on c3 Bishop e2 I think mano savage end
up castling to the Queen side and it was
very interesting Sharpe game and then
you played f3 and calls and started to
advancing the pants on the Queen side so
you can take a look at this game and
you'll find interesting the game
eventually ended in a draw so this is
another possibility here to take but
very important to remember after you
take you have to play Queen d2 first if
you just play this move
for example after c5 now black has a
very good game here but I played Bishop
h4 now he took joke now I play Bishop g7
another move in this position is he
takes c4 but now white plays III white
wants to get the pawn back on c4 and try
to have a strong center here in a
meantime why a black needs to try to
play c5 here to put some pressure so
this is a different line so normally if
it takes III Bishop e6 played Knight f3
Bishop g7 and now it's a very
interesting move I played rugby one
couple of times in this position had
some good results with it but very
interesting move here is queen b 1 from
the first glance it looks like a very
strange move but the idea behind this
move is in the main lines with group b 1
let's say b6 when you go Knight g5 he
goes we should be 5 + e 4 he always has
this h6 move and now you cannot move the
knight because you will lose the pawn on
e4 and if you take only 5 dispositions I
consider that Y doesn't have much
advantage here then he takes on d5 so
the idea behind Queen B 1 here is that
you attack the pawn on b7 and when you
place b6
you go Knight g5 and now if you place
bishop d v e4 there was a very nice game
played between Morrison CO and navara
last year at the World Cup so now when
you play it for yes
I check taxi in this position Oh
and after what what if it plays c6 now
he's blocking the check and also now
attacking on the Queen back back it up
here and then if you place a 5c we lose
a lot of time now with this checks now
we have to move the Queen again and if
we go here now he can push again so yeah
so it's not that good for a so-so double
bad idea is you play Knight g5 now
Bishop b5 you play E for and when you
place this move h6 more single actually
went not Knight f3 he went Knight h3 an
idea is if you go Bishop e6 here you can
go Knight f4 attacking the bishop and
eventually you get upon on c4 here if
you're going to get the palm back and
you still have the control the center
white is clearly better here but if you
go back Knight f3 then Bishop e6 it's
not so clear if you're actually getting
the palm back
I like these positions for white
sometimes I even play these positions
without even taking the palm just
because I have to control the center but
here I don't have the d5 move because he
has this Bishop c3 but this kind of
positions you can just play positionally
Bishop e2 Castle Rock d1 and you
definitely have a compensation here so
this could be something for you to play
if you know against the grünfeld defense
so queen b1 it's very interesting move
there are a lot of games played with
this move but my opponent played Bishop
g7 I played
III nya plates e5 Knight f3 knight c6
all this is theory takes 20 xt5 Bishop
e2 now I cancelled iCal so now in this
position after we both Castle what is
white threatening here if let's say he
plays like move like b6 for example what
is my threat here
it's not like I'm winning the game or
anything but I get a really nice
position after this how c4 now I go
screen d7 for example
d5 right now you attack tonight if you
place 95 you can simply exchange and
bring the route back on c1 in this
positions are considered much better for
white because then you have the
potential of pushing f-4e for and you
have a very strong Center basically you
have a knight on d5 pawn on d5 versus
the pawn on d6 so this is much better
and you can advance your Center will
discuss that your question is that okay
okay we're going to discuss that next
so if Bishop takes a 1 you simply play
queen takes a one now and attacking the
knight so he needs to move the knight
now question is where if you put the
knight on probably you want to put the
knight on a 5 here but now White has a
very good compensation for the exchange
because first of all his dark square
Bishop is gone so it's dark squares are
very weak and you have a very strong
center I would probably just continue
with E 5 before you have a strong center
see five is six ideas you can also play
Bishop h6 Bishop g5 Bishop h6 if fish
base which basics I would just play
either Queen c3 or Roxy one so this is a
it's not like you're winning the game
immediately here but you definitely have
a very strong compensation and strong
attacking chances here so if you have an
opportunity you definitely want to go
for a position like this a lot of times
the bishop on g7 in a groom field that's
it's worth more than the rook on a one
but there are also some lines where
black can take but not in this position
here definitely white is better because
position also close so the rooks are not
very effective here he needs to open up
lines which is not so easy to do in this
position so that's that's why in this
position black always takes on d4 so he
take he took I took and there are two
moles here for black you can play e5 and
after they exchange
rook FD one night xe5 white is slightly
better in this position because white is
a better development and if you take on
f3 he will go Bishop f3 slightly better
I think there was a game played between
shear of Rajab of shear of few years ago
and maybe maybe played Knight d4 here
this is a better move in order to
prevent the Bishop from coming to e6
because if you play it okay c1 he might
play Bishop e6 and equalize but now you
put the knight on before you stop Bishop
e6 and then you play it okay c1 it's a
pleasant position for white to play here
and also he constantly needs to watch
out for the f4 move slightly Plus here
yeah I would probably if let's say Q
equal players play so maybe I think
white will win 55% of the time something
like that maybe a little bit more it
depends also you know which player
prefers this kind of position more some
players like to have the Queen's on some
players really like to go for the
endgame early in the game so but my
opponent didn't play e5 he played Bishop
f5 now I want you to think here and try
to see how you would continue in this
position so he just developed his piece
and so there are some games played in
this position so what can I do here
group to see one is a possibility but
your pawn is hanging on a 2 so okay well
let's take a look it's not so simple
here so you wanna push defy right okay
Bishop c4 first probably he will play
queen a3 to protect on e7 and after d5
maybe just Knight a5
yeah you don't have row k1 anymore
because [ __ ] these patients are very
active now so to be careful when you
push the 5 you may think you move the
knife but then suddenly this Bishop is
now very active if you play d5
immediately let's see
there's also the possibility of just
playing [ __ ] FDA now pinning and if you
play Bishop c4 just Queen a5
this is another idea but perhaps maybe
have Queen b3 here yeah you probably
have clean b3 here so just clean a tree
here just to keep the Queen I think it's
very well placed here because protecting
only seven and then I'm ready to move
the knight only five Oh long before yeah
also cannot yeah yeah in this position
still our Knight e5 I guess takes Bishop
e5 Bishop this out I have some some
compensation here but not so clear if
it's enough because it's got two
connected passed pawns so and it's not
so clear
now I didn't want to play Roxie one
immediately because you know you only
sacrifice a pawn yet
you know what can you do here
ninety-two is an idea it's a pretty
standard idea in this kind of positions
they move the night in order white moves
the night in order to play Bishop f3 I
thought of that ideal so but I just
wanted to kind of develop my major
pieces at this point because I develop
the minor pieces I have some control of
the center but I really need to get my
Queen into the game and also develop my
rocks so you need to find a good square
for the Queen to go to here
you could go Queen b3 but again not it's
bitterly it's not so clear maybe we'll
have a very slight plus in that position
but not so in not so clear
absolutely Queen a for activating the
Queen connecting the rooks and now I'm
ready to play rook c1 here
my opponent played rook F c8 quick Queen
a4 yeah I like this move I like this
move because queen is active and now I'm
I connected my rocks now you need to
continue now question is which rook now
you want to put on a C file obviously
that should be my next move here I
cannot put a look on a b1 square because
the bishop is guarding it so I need to
realize which rook now that I want to
put on c1 okay why why do you think it's
better to put the rook on that rope
absolutely cannot move and also I can
never push defy because I always have to
worry about my rope hanging that's how
you realize you that you want to prove
this piece here because if you think ok
I will put this rope here and later on
maybe put this you could think that way
too you know because you know there's
open file you can have open file you can
think about that but you have to look
concrete you know first you need to move
this Bishop which is not so clear how
you're going to move it from there in
order to bring this piece and a lot of
the tactical lines you have to now look
for the e4 if I have move because in a
lot of these lines this rook is going to
be hanging so that's why you play rook F
rook a c1 now I'm threatening to play
rook c5 and simply double up the rooks
so it seems like a simple position to
play because both players are you know
you know developing their piece but it's
not so easy for black because I have a
concrete idea I just want to go rook c5
rook F c1 to put pressure if it tries to
play b6 this is very bad for him
why why this is bad for him
be sure to a6 attacking the rook if the
rook moves you take the knight so he has
to go rook c7 bishop g3 pulling prussia
if he moves the rook you take the knight
okay so you cannot do anything now I
mean he has to play e5 but he will be
losing at least upon now so it's not so
easy to stop this idea so now he played
Queen d6
now what King Bishop is hanging so you
need to think in this position because
now I have a it's almost a forced line
after which I'm going to have a very
pleasant endgame the line that leads to
this end game which White is I think
probably much better how can I get to
that end game with the advantage now
rook c5 it's not that good because you
can play b6 so you kind of made a
preventing movie drop the Queen early
defended only seven and you could go
Bishop g3 but then he can probably go
just Queen d7
so you
there should be five is a possibility
but if I take on c6 even if I give him a
weak pawn it's going to be very hard to
win this position because like let's say
we play a six he doesn't have to play
six but even if let's say plays a six
now Bishop takes rook takes
and now he wants to play c5 and I'm
probably still slightly better after
Brooke c1 but he has a pair of the
bishops so even even if we get into an
end game where I win this pawn but I end
up with the bishop and night he has two
bishops he has excellent drawing chances
because he can exchange dark square
bishop for my night and have opposite
color bishop so it's just his get he has
lots of drawing chances here so that's
why I don't want to play Bishop b5
immediately and another idea he might
just go be should be seven and then I
cannot take on c6 because he'll take
back with the bishop it's it's kind of
concrete idea here not so easy to see
but if you think about it you attack
something you try to weaken the position
that's what you're trying to do here
what can you attack to create some
weaknesses think about it b1 well
remember remember the bishop write this
that's the reason I brought this rook
here not the other one because I can
never put the rook here d5 and if he
just takes
well you probably get some temples but I
don't think miking is very safe so
you're not going to be able to you know
attack me because I'm just very safe
here
so I probably just go maybe I'm just
Queenie five
about what intention upon the uniforms
of 15 years
Aoife but we won't play for well the
thing is once you play for then you're
going to make this piece is very strong
because they're going to be now putting
pressure on before so now a kind of this
Bishop is on this diagonal but it's not
very effective because of the pawn on e3
and before so I don't think I want to
push
efore here anytime soon so I want try to
attack and induce some weaknesses now
and I'm focusing on playing on a queen
side right now
I'm not thinking about attack here
because it's not practical he's too
strong so I want to try to get some
advantage on the Queen side I'm sorry
92 it's possible more but again once you
move this knight you always have to
watch out for the e5 move because you
know you weaken the control of that
square so he could possibly play e5 92
is possible but we have a correct
suggestion here Quinby 5 yes excellent
now it's a simple move but it gives
black lots of headache now I just simply
want to take this pawn and you'll be
surprised it's very difficult for him
now to make a move no no it's a big
difference
first of all Queen b3 can will run into
95 tempo so that's why Queen f3 so this
is a very strong move here and now this
move establishes the clear advantage for
white let's take a look why I'm
attacking the pawn do you see any good
way he can defend this pawn first of all
90-80 also there is also queenie 8 ideas
so very dangerous queen can come to 8
and so 98 it's not that good so if you
put something on b8 or c7 if you push
the rock here what's going to happen do
you see the move Bishop G train is going
to have big problems here on this
diagonal so looks like it doesn't have
done many options if you place Queen d7
why is he losing you just play d5 he has
to move the knight can't even go to a5
and basically you just you win the pawn
on this 7 here there are a few ways how
you can do you can take only 5 first
then take or you can exchange on this 7
and still win the pond so you win upon
on these 7 here so that's why he didn't
play that move so now and if you place
ok let's take a look at the side and I
played b6 so now he weakened the
position h6 square is weak which is
gonna be very important and down now
knight on c6 also it's not as well
protected how we can try to put some
more pressure now double the rooks is an
idea but let's try to gain some valuable
tempo here don't rush don't rush you can
play d5 but then he goes 95 perhaps
absolutely bishop g3 now attacking on
the Queen now he has to go back Queen d7
only move because if he goes to e6 he
loses to d5 so now he goes Queen d7 and
now he wants to you know maybe play
Knight a5 and get out of this pin by the
way do you see why he cannot play this
move
rook takes night and then if it takes we
can take check or we can even take
immediately okay so you play Queen d7
now by the way there was a variation I
wanted to show you so let me just
mention if you would have played queen
before that's why this was very strong
fun because now if I play this move I
have a strong idea here rook takes c6
and now you cannot take back his Queen
is hanging and if it takes my queen I go
in between move rook texier check he
takes back they should be five and I'm
up piece so he played Queen d7 sorry
played b6 bishop g3 Queen d7 now what do
you do because you have to play very
energetically here if you give you know
if you play slowly he will bring the
bishop on e4 and he will you know try to
consolidate his position here
very good now I also control the e5
square so you cannot bring the knight
here so he has to go to a5 I mean 98 is
probably another option for him but
Knight will be very passive here so he
went to a little bit more active square
Queen takes Queen first correct Bishop
takes Queen aha
this is the whole point of inducing him
to play big sis because I get the bishop
a six in this position and now I will
get the control of the open file and I'm
going to be able to activate my rook to
the seventh rank and after this also
bishop on a6 is an example where the
bishop on a sick a six simply dominates
the knight on a five and you can get
this kind of positions a lot in groom
field where black has two on one here
but the bishop on e6 is just simply
dominating the night because Knight has
no squares to go to
so now my opponent went King f8 he sees
that I'm trying to go rook c7 so he
wants to be prepared so when I go to see
seven like for example if he would have
played h6 then I go duck c7 now if you
move the bishop I will win the pawn only
seven and he cannot move the rook from a
file because he loses the pawn on a
seven so he doesn't have done many moves
it's just after forcing in b6 is just
now clearly better for white but let's
see now how you can improve this
position to get to the winning position
here course rooks e7 is the most natural
move very tempting to play but I don't
want to rush rock c7 is not going to go
anywhere I can play this move next move
but I have a better move here something
first
I could play 95 but White is still much
better after 95 it's it's a fine move
but better something better here it's
white to play ok think don't rush think
ok what well you could I mean even even
after h3 White is still probably much
better but there is no danger of
background checkmate
yeah but there is no danger of
background checkmate right now so ok all
right let's
no no night before he takes in you know
you don't want to get double pawns here
absolutely
efore consolidate the center and ready
to advance these pawns okay that's what
I will now I'm ready to advance these
pawns very good move now I place h6
trying to control
the g5 squares so when I go to Roxy
seven I don't have this night I don't
have the ninety five idea okay
now what do you do don't rush don't rush
now you have a piece that you want to
activate remember after this move I'll
tell you why I played efore first
okay but knife is okay right now which
piece you definitely want to activate
absolutely see the difference is if I
play Roxy seven here it's probably still
very good for me but he has this Bishop
f5 move then he stops him from playing
efore and i really want to have the pawn
on e4 because it protects my Center also
restricts his light square bishop that's
why so and rook c7 he can't really
prevent me but he can prevent me from
playing e4 so absolutely it's a good
move because my place h6 now we go rook
c7 now if they skinned e8
my opponent is an international master
David proofs yeah
now what do you do here by the way he
wants to play King d8 and after he plays
King the end yes you have a nice
position everything is very nice for you
but you still need to find a way to
break through so I need to do something
because after king da Denia my rook is
very active but I'm not winning any puns
and then I won't be able to play even if
I because he will take my rook normally
in a position like this you don't want
to exchange too many pieces because his
pieces you know I mean yeah but if you
look at the position which Bishop buting
it's stronger here my bishop on GT or
his Bishop on g7 my bishop right it's
more active history his bishop is really
like open diagonal but not really doing
anything so my bishop is causing in more
trouble and now if I exchange the
bishops in he can go clean d8 and they
maybe try to move and Bishop e5 he might
be able to play Bishop f8 so 925 is a
move I thought a bit but what about
Bishop a4 I didn't see anything after
Bishop a4 anything concrete he goes
which pay for and I don't have anything
excellent excellent suggestion v5 you
have that central pass and you want to
put the spots into use by advancing
getting more control and now if he goes
King d8 which he did what are you going
to do d6
absolutely now you put the pawn on d6
now strengthen the position of that rock
now I'm ready to improve the position of
the night and black doesn't have that
many moves so I played Bishop f8 now
in few more most basically black is
going to run out of moves
excellent now you bring the knight into
the game activating the night and you
can see clearly that white pieces are
simply dominating my rook is more active
all my pieces are more active than his
and also I have the center my rookies on
a 7th rank very difficult to find a move
for him move that doesn't make the
position even worse so now he plays
Bishop c8 at least he's trying to get
rid of my strong bishop on 86 because do
you see anything for black here do you
see some good defensive moves for
example he can do I mean really the
knight cannot move rook cannot move the
light square Bishop only can go to see
it which he did so do you see anybody do
you see any defensive moves for black
here that he can really do and I mean he
can play for example e 6 but that will
be very bad because now my pawn is
protected passed pawn and I will
strengthen my center with f4 and now I'm
turning to go Bishop h4 so this is just
winning yes it looks like you could do
this move but after the take the
question is what are you going to do
next
and take I take and protect the bishop
yes yes and now by the way one of my
ideas here is just simply to come to b5
and win the pot on a seven that's one of
my ideas here so basically yeah in this
position he doesn't really have many
moves that he can play so he played
Bishop c8 yes in this position no well
let's see in this position let's say he
makes a random move like something like
this okay so we go now I'm not even sure
if this that's my best move this should
be five might be even stronger actually
here whereas a mission b5 might be
stronger but let's say I play 95 we
should be 5 cake and it let's look see
it yes so now why to play what's the
best move in this position check
check and mate excellent so you can't
really do much so he played you play
Bishop c8 now what do you do though
again if you play inaccurately here if
let's say you take on city is going to
take back with the rook and it's back in
the game because there is a background
check made you cannot take on a seven
now you get a background check mate
exactly but exactly but I don't have to
take the bishop rest and I don't have to
take the bishop now because you know my
bishop is more active my rook is more
active so I'm not going to this will be
a very bad move actually this way you
would lose all your advantage if you
play this move here so what do you do
now
what excellent move Bishop b5 now he
lost control of this diagonal you can't
really move anything so he played a6
continued
don't rush think yeah I mean when you're
winning you think possible possible what
else what else I have here there I
believe most of the moves suggested are
winning here but you have something that
is a little bit more precise that
doesn't allow any contra play it's very
important in a winning position like
this you try to win without allowing any
contra play excellent
even though Knight is on the side of the
board but it's kind of a good defender
so now we exchange this Knight
now we take with a bishop now rook has
only one move rook b8 now you need to
calculate what is the winning move here
you still you still want to suggest this
hc7 but if Bishop takes it's probably
winning probably winning but he kind of
when you make a move like D Texas semi
kind of give him little space now you
know then he might be able to do
something have to make sure you continue
squeezing in this position excellent
very good d7 now I sacrifice my rook but
his Bishop is trapped so he doesn't have
any option so he has to take which I did
is six check now this Bishop comes into
the game and now if it takes very
important how to take the bishop because
it just takes and also very important
not to take the rook because after
Bishop d7 actually black wins okay so
you simply queen and win immediately
because you win the bishop and you win
the roof so this is the most precise way
to win there are many other ways to win
but this is stronger so after I played
is six check he went back continue
take the rock now his Bishop is trapped
so he is losing the piece so he played
one more few more moves he took now I
take his bishop he took and what's the
best move here after which my opponent
resigned I mean most of the moves are
winning but the strongest move is
absolutely bishop goes back to the five
and now basically he cannot move this
bishop he cannot move to g7 he cannot
move on this diagonal and his King his
King is also a I cannot go anywhere so
it plays h6 now h5 now I simply play h4
Bishop h6 and f4 lock the bishop and
whites just wins so after I play Bishop
e5 my opponent resigned and I like this
game because it looked like in the
opening it was just absolutely normal
position both players develop their
piece but suddenly I had this queen b5
move after which you know black is
experiencing many problems and then I
got a nice advantage after b6 and
exchanging and getting the bishop on e6
so this is a kind of a famous study so
if you familiar with this study please
raise your hand white to play and win
I've seen this position in few books
your pawn is on b7 and you're trying to
Queen this pawn yeah
yes but the thing is different problem
with you the the problem the problem is
we're pinned that's the whole problem
yes that would be very nice but we can't
so nobody is familiar with this position
so yeah okay well let's think first
normally in this kind of studies you
need to find really extraordinary ideas
very rarely you would see like a check
to be the solution even like a natural
check and I can tell you why queen f1
for example because it's very hard to
make progress I'm just going to go back
and forth so you really have to find a
deep move and the idea here to win and
if he takes you don't want to do that
you don't want to lose the winning
position so
okay and if it goes queen king b6 so
from where there are many squares to
check from which square okay see again
this usually you know it's not a check
check solution usually because we're not
going to be making progress I mean you
can check me again but I go here without
making progress so let's go back to the
original position so I don't want to
give you a hint yet I want you to find a
first move whoa
very good but why why do you play Queen
before that is excellent that is
excellent very good thinking you put a
queen on before now King has no squares
to go to that means he has to move the
Queen right he cannot move the Queen too
many squares because he needs to make
sure he keep the pin so he can go to
this four squares it's a very nice idea
Queen before now let's take a look at
this Queen D 5 moles
can win yet so you need to find a nice
idea in order to win here
scary huh we never check he has to go to
b6 better think think about what can you
try to do here again if I give you a
hint you'll find it right away let's try
to see if you can see an idea very good
idea yes
so Queen b3 is the idea check deflecting
the Queen from the diagonal but first we
have to force the King on a B file so
when he takes you promote a pawn into a
queen and you skewer him excellent idea
so but you know the only way you can get
to this is you have to play a queen
before first move if you just check
checking and you're not going to be able
to get there so now let's take a look at
the next idea if it goes Queen f3 we're
going to do one by one so same idea
check and it goes here same idea works
because we deflect the Queen and then we
promote into a queen and window Queen so
he has to play queen g2 now
very good he has to go here be - same
idea check he has to take but now we
have a move like Queen h1 now same idea
it's not going to work here because I'm
planning to bring my King to c7 what do
you do now and this is a study if you do
it once you're going to remember for a
very long time this idea that deflecting
the coin idea
you could do that but just go back
Quincy for he just goes back to b6
King b5
yeah you'll be surprised it that's so
easy to promote this one because he is
going to check and pin you
six check
you could do that but again King b5
like Queen d2
well you can't just go back actually so
we have to do it again wait Queen were
here he can push the pawn your PIN still
so you can only sacrifice your queen if
you deflect the Queen from this diagonal
so let's take a look what's what's
happening now if we just check right
check check
now if you go here you can win with the
same method check and check
same method works but the problem we
have that he goes here right so he
doesn't get he doesn't get excellent now
that's why you have to always look at
the whole board you can just look you
know this Socrates you have to look at
the whole board to find the move Queen
each to check sacrificing the Queen he
has to take it and now b8 Queen skewer
wins the game okay well let's go back
and do this again okay because I want to
make sure that you will remember this
for a very long time okay this idea so
the most important thing you need to do
here is you have to take away all the
squares the King can go to so first you
play which move Queen before now these
are the squares you can go to so if it
goes Queen b5 Queen f3 Queen G - the
same idea works you simply check from
the a file and then go Queen veto so
let's take a look again if Queen f3
check and now Queen b3
if it goes Queen G to use the same idea
but a little bit different you have to
go Queen a three Queen B to check and
quit excellent so he has to go Queen h1
now check it goes back here if it goes
to a six then you use the same idea
right we used a couple of times so you
check and clean b1 so hard move to cease
Queen h2 because we're kind of so
focused on this idea trying to do on the
Queen side but you always have to look
at the whole board and now in this
position you play queen h2 deflecting
the Queen takes b8 queen king c5 here
yeah king c5 yes you will just go King
c7 and I think the only way to stop the
the promotion is to play queen h7 but
then you simply play Queen b6 check if
he goes king c4 you move the King away
to c6 and now he cannot do anything to
stop b8 Queen he doesn't have any checks
and if you would have played this move
now you can actually even go back
because you block this diagonal so he
cannot pin the pawn anymore
so you will win the game also you could
win the game by clinking a6 and if you
go screen you to check you just exchange
Queens between the pond okay so it's
very important to do study so I
recommend before also and now again just
try to do some studies if you can do
even five studies per week that will be
great now just you know try to get the
book or maybe from Internet also if you
search chest out this I'm sure you will
find a lot of studies that you can print
and just work on